O ne o
[Müzik]
ilk öncelikle hepinize tekrardan merhaba
demek istiyorum Bu sahnede birçok defa
bulundum Ama sanırım renkte Canısı bir
Çorlu'da bildiği gibi Ben Bir Öğretmenim
1970 yılında doğmuştur öğretmenim
gençliğin gözünden baktığımda başka bir
asıl başka bir dünyamızı savunmasında
hata olmanın gözünden değil gerçekten de
başka bir Aslında sana oldum artık
mağazası onların gözünde 50 yer 40 yaş
30 yaş gerçekten çok uzak bir dünya
Hatta zaman zaman ben olarak şöyle
söylüyorum 30 yaşına geldiğinizde
hayatınız mp2000l mi yaşayacak
Ama genel olarak onlarda bunu
söyleyeceğim yapmayınca 30 yaş mı o
zamana kadar ölmüş olurum ben
maalesef insan gençken yaşlı çok uzak
bir dönem olarak görüntü gençlik
insanımızın önemli O zaman kocaman bir
fark yaratıyor çok derin kocaman
dalgalarla boğuşuyor gençlikte Ama bu
dalgalarla boğuşmak gençlik yıllarında o
kadar da zor değil Çünkü içlerinde heves
var Enerji vartal kartları var ve en
önemlisi de bozuklukları var Oradan
baktıklarında da bizim yaşımızda kilerin
onluklarını o enerjilerini o isteklerini
kavga ettiklerini düşünüyorlar ve
diyorlar ki artık okyanuslarla kullan
hayatında sadece Durgun bir deniz var
Belki vardır bir nebze Serinlemek abone
ol
Ama gerçekten bugün
bir
yaşanmışlık
konuşma onca Ayrılık oyuncağını bulmuş
gibi içinde bulunmuştu koca Sevda
oyuncak aldı onca insan olunca mekan
Ya aslında insan yaşadıkça Berzan tersi
daha fazla Sallıyormuşum Çünkü arkasına
dönüp baktığımda kocaman bir daha var
yaşanmışlıklardan olsa ederim baktığımda
şunu söyleyeyim sen Bye bye bye
37 yaşındaydın O dediğin sokağa çıktım
Oraya
1977 sokakta oynayan çocuklar
en iyi arkadaşım var Yani bu da Yaşasın
sese koyuyor başka sonra Bayram döndü
bu Meryem Sizin bir şey çıktı vicdanı
çocuklar Biz Meryem oyun havası hep
beraber biliyor musun
O bizim sonra ya da muhtaç gideceğimizi
bu Meryem adamı tanıyorsun beni Gülümse
daldıkça ben çok seviyorum çünkü çok
tehlikeli yabancıların olduğu yerde
durulmaz biraz Dizi seyrediyorum Sonra
dedi ki çocuklar çok yoğunuz Hadi
isterseniz sırtındaki Bakkala gidelim
size şeker olurum ben o kadar çok
korktum ki hemen yapmış zeynep'te
ortamdan Beni takip et
Meryem s adamın elini tutup arkaya doğru
olmaz
O bizim önemli gitti bir cuma akşamı
internet falan yoktu kötü aldım de çok
hızlı yazıyorum O zaman
pazartesi sabah gazetede gördüm öyle bir
resmini
küçücük beni o kutuların içindeydi
parçalanmış dolgulu kadının elini
demişti Ben de
bu Meryem öncüsü Ben 7 yaşında
var ya hayatımda ilk defa para kötülükle
Hanım ölümle geliştir
bu ne Şundan da çok sayıda ördüm gördüm
daha sonra da Ölüm benim için Meryem'in
olsun siyah gözlerinde kaldı
bu iki oldu görüntü yok Neden bunlar
benim başıma geliyor diye ağlamaya
geçecektim ya da diyecektim ki hayatı
daha fazlasını Çünkü gerçekten bugün
hayatında olan insanlar Yarın da
olmayabilir
Ya da sen benim hayatımda olduğun
insanları Beş dakika sonra Hayatımdan
çık gidebilirsin o zaman insanları çok
sevmek gerektiğini aldım İnsanlara çok
sıkı sarılmak gerektiğini gördüm de
hayatın her anının ne kadar değerli
olduğunu çok küçük yaşımdan itibaren
anlamışsınızdır Ondan sonra hep yaşamın
Caddesi geçti hayatım Uyanınca yazacağım
ne olursa olsun
12 topu
o ceviz sancı çok okula çok
yasaklanabilir görüşe ya da çavdar
tarlası çocukları
başka altına alıp 16 yaşında bir lise
ördüm çok az okuldan atılıyor seni ama
Oh onun parmağında Oğlum oğlum bakış
açısından baktığımızda çevresindeki
herkes Hatta alsın Çünkü insan
yetişkinle şiştikçe sakinleşiyor yani
öğretmenlerin müdürleri müdür
yardımcıları ve hatta anne-babası Her
hareketinden sahtelik akıyor ya oğlum bu
saatte uyum sağlayamıyorum seni
istediğim kendi gibi olabilmek Ama okul
kuralları Hayat olun kendisi gibi
olmasını asla müsade ettim isyan
ediyordu ve okuldan atıldığında evine
gitmek görmek ne yok sokaklarında
çıkıyor kafasına ters patlıyor
şapkasıyla iyi o sokaklarında hayatın
anlamını sorulur bu
olduğunda birlikte hayatın anlamını
sorgulamaya kitabı
ve neyin kötü olduğunu sordum yani kötü
değil neye görünüyorsunuz diyor Biz
İnsanlar neden Sevmedik bazı Neden
kızıyorsun bizim istediklerimizi yapmak
için
ve hemen ardından
bugün de John steinbeck'in cennetin
doğusu kitabını biri uyarlanmış aldım
başladı efsane otu keyfi iki kardeş var
gibi iki erkek kardeş plastik Habil
Kabil hikayesi
cevizinin oynadı Kağıt karakteri kötü
Karadır Ne yapsam babasına ailesine
yaramıyor ne olacak inanılmaz bir
Mücadele veriyor ama her seferinde Urfa
pazarda çok acımasız hiç acıma yok
hı hı hı
bu işte sabah oldu metal etimiz
piştikten sonra yorum öğretmen olmaya
karar
o Çünkü artık insanların içinde hiç
görmediğiniz bir yer olduğunu biliyorum
ve öğretmenliği bulunacak öğrencilerin
görmediğim yerlerini görme odaklanır
kendi kötü dediğimiz Uyumsuz dediğimiz
hızımız bağırdığınız sistemi şey
yaptığımız insanların Aslında kadar
kıymetli onları olduğunu onları
dinleyince onlara şans gelince
deneyimlemiş oldum
tek bir kişinin şans vermesi bir kişinin
deneyimlemesi yeter mi Evet dedik birçok
insanın birçok insanı dinlenebilmesi
anlayabilmesi ve görünenin ardındaki
görmesi gerekiyor Sun hava şuna yazdım
hiç kimse olmasın da alsak bir kimse
olması çok daha
Bu 24 yaşındaki Verem olur hiç aylık
anneyi bebeğim çok küçüktüm Ben
hamilelikten hiçbir şey alma değilim
yapmadan önce zannediyordum ki dünyanın
yükünü omuzlarında
yıl 1994 Türkiye'ye gelen ağabey
ekonomik krizin içinde sağ zaten
Piyasalar kötü olan yüksek Mart yüksek
umutsuz bir durum var ortada Ben küçük
bir bebekle başından boyundan büyük
değişik almışım Nasıl yapacağım diye
Kendime soruyorum ama annem var Nasıl
sahnem araba kalbim annedükkan Anladığım
bu
daha sonra
ağır grip geçirdim bir türlü iyileşmedi
bu 70 yaşında anneannemle evde dedi ki
bu kızla ateşleniyor 37 derece öksürüyor
sırt ağrısı Gece terlemeleri olur mu
dedik bu devirde neden olur gitmedik
Doktor ettim geçer tartı 48 kilo
gösterdiğinde artık doktora gitmemiz
gerektiğini Anladım doktoru
değişikliğiyle anneannemin Perisi bir
bira Yediveren
oluştu gerçek ondan sonrası üç ay bir
sanatoryumda herkesin uzak gece demiş
bir yaşa Öncelikle Dinç aylık bebeğiyle
Kağıt okuma kendine dövme ve hayatı
sorgulamadım
O benim memleket iş maal oluyor öğrendim
sağlık Çünkü veren bitir Hayır yine geri
döndüm de orada beraber hayatı tekrar
keşfedildiğini gördüm onunla birlikte
sonbahar yapraklarının sesini dinledim
Karaca videolarını izledim oturup
kitaplar yazdım resimler çizdim birlikte
oynadığım parça dalga bildim ağaçları
tırmandım ve yapamazsın sıkıntıların
gücünü ve yaşama devam edebilmenin
keyfini bir kez almış oldu oğlum bir
daha asla geri gelmeyecek çocukluğunu
sonuna kadar işe girmiş oldum sağlıyorum
bu gelişmenin bana çok önemli bir
katkısı olur
O 30 yaşına geldim
en ucuz Babam geldi
çok ateşlendi akşam hastanede yedik
sabah mı olur eminim ki bu Tom Annene
iyi bak dedi bana Ve bu son sözleri
Benim de onu sormuşum
Ondan sonra babamın mü bana çok ağrıyor
çünkü babamın Dükkanı hemen sonra evinde
aldığı gün geçmişten hayatım su
işleriyle uğraşmak zorunda kaldım
elektrik faturalarının üstüne geçiriyor
kredi kartlarını top atma balık
hesapları ile ilgilenmek ve bunun
hepsini hemen yapmak zorundayım
ve En sevdiğiniz nasıl toprağım
görüşürüz içimizde kocaman bir pop ama
hayat sizi devam etmeye zorluyor
bu topa yıllar gibi oldu Umudumu
kaybetmiyorum Aşk
ve
babamın önünden tam bir çay sonra Teyzem
de kucağımda kaybedince gerçekten Hayata
Küstüm
Ama bu sefer bir yol seçti kendimi
acımaya başladı artık hiçbir şeyden
öğretmenliği bırakmak istiyorum hayatını
değiştirebilecek müdür
bu takibi akşam
nedir
yıllardır görmediğim bir çocukluk
arkadaşımla başlıyor arkadaşım bir
Tekstil şirketinde nelerdir durumu
anlayınca ona dedi ki yabancı dil
konusunda hiçbir sıkıntı yok bizim şimdi
çok Rahatlıkla yaparsın geldim kitapta
Bizim şirkette işe yarar Nasıl olur
yıllarca öğretmenlik yapıyorum başka
hiçbir iş bilmiyorum
bu hafta düşündüm önündekine içiyorlar
da yok hacı oğlu arıyorum da dümdüz
devam edecektim Ya hepimiz sırtıma alıp
yepyeni hikayeler yazmak için Yola
çıkıyor
ama ben Cesaret edip köşede olmuyorsun
da
tam dört yıl çalıştık çok fazla
söylüyorum bugün yaptığın Öğretmenlik
mesleğini de katkısı olan gerçekten çok
önemli değil dedim bir gün bir çantanın
imalatı için toplantıya girdik çok
önemli bir film alın çok pahalı çantası
toplantı Tam üç sal günü saat boyunca o
çantanın kilidini nereye koyduğunu tane
altın sarısı olsun Razı olsun olsun
Sonra baktım ki ben toplantıda kopmuşum
hiçbir şekilde dinleyemiyorum yapılan
bir şey gitti gitti olmadığı için değil
ama Benim kulağım daha uzun ve kalın
sesi olmuş öğrencilerin beni çağır
hayatın anlamını gelmiş gibisindir Bu
karar verdim bir kez dahi bizim yaptım
ve yokum
ve tekrar öğretmenleri
en çok sevdiğim okulda çok keyifli bir
şekilde öğretmenliğe devam ederken 45
yaşına geldim Dedim ki artı taraf
değişmez geceleri büyüdüm Bundan sonra
bu çizgide akar gider daha ettim
mutluyum bugün bir arkadaşım olabilir bu
Trabzon Gezelim Görelim Bak burada çok
güzeldi kalktım geldim Sadece merak Çok
yakın bir arkadaşım da değilim
Bir iki gün arkadaşımla beraberken
burada bir arkadaşıyla buluşmak
istediğini benim dolma katılıp
katılmayacağını daha önceden verilmiş
bir sözü olduğunu söyledi Tamam dedim
arkadaşımla beraber onun arkadaşıyım
görüşürüz ve arkadaşı O zaman bu kurumda
müdürü olan kişi okul yeni açılıyormuş
lise bulacakmış ve Yabancı Diller için
öğretmene ihtiyaç vardır sohbetin konusu
değil Hatta ben sohbetim okuduğumuz
yaptım ki Şubat ayı olmasına rağmen
deniz kenarında ayağını bize sormuştum
çünkü çok keyifli bir ortamımız
ya Oğuz Siz gelir misiniz denir
gelmem dedim ne işin var Üstelik ben tam
bir İstanbul aşığı İzmir'de hiç para
kalmadı bir kimseyi tanırım Ne bilelim
bir kez gelmiş bunlara Hayırdır sonra
dedim ardından defalarca aranmaya
başlanır o kadar çok geldi İzmir'den
arabana durdum düşündüm İzmir sanki beni
çağırdı tekrar görüşene ruhum ayağa
kalkmıştı gene bir karar vermem
gerekiyordu ve 45 yaşında gerek kocaman
bir değişiklik yapmamı bekliyordun
cesaret ettim bu değişikliği yok ve
[Müzik]
idrar ediyorum hayatımın en zorları uğra
da yaşadım ona buraya geri döndüm
işareti ona çok sıcak Hiçbir zaman bu
düşüreceksin asla bekleme olmaz vesaire
şey ama geldim Yok ilk kar tatilini 35
yıl sonra bu şekilde İzmirliler ve hemen
aldım şiddetinde deprem oldu çalışırken
Bunun dışında bak çok fazla zorluk
yaşadığını Çünkü insan kendi ülkesinde
bir yoksa başka bir şeyle Türkiye'nin
çok farklı olduğunu gördüm Başka
insanlar başka kültür başka okul ve
tamamen Yalnız hiç arkadaşım yok bugün
gerçekten çok zor lan baktım ki bu
zorlanma Ne yapıyorsun da sürekli
şikayet ediyorum ama devam
bu insanlar da Aşağıya gidiyorum
kendinden şikayet ediyorum ya buradayım
diye şikayet ediyorum şehirde şikayet
ediyorum izlemedim ama böyle diyorum
bu fark ettim ki şikayet edince
cesaretini kaydediyorum ilahi yapıyor
istediğiniz başarı elde edemiyoruz Çünkü
aslında çok daha fazlasını yapabilirim
ama yapamıyorum duruyor mu Çünkü
aşırılıklar beni bul duruyor
bu burada yaşadıkları ama şikayet etmem
gerekiyor
O zaman
sadece şu farketti eve gidiyorum bütün
şifrelerimi 6 sıra oluyor Bugünlerde
farkettim diyorum Neyi Değiştirdin mi
şikayetim var
Ama bakıyorum hiçbir şey cevap hep
hiçbir şey
ne kadar doğru olduğunu ben buradayım
şikayetinin olduğu yerde gerçekten
cesareti geliyor
ayakkabı yürü cesaretinin şikayet sizden
alıp deden artık ne zaman bir şeyden
şikayet etmeye baksam 15 dakika
duruyorum kendimi susturuyorum ya
yatırımda kitapların varsa bir kitap
açıp çok sevdiğim bir paragraf okuyorum
yarışı yapıyorum yani şeyler yazıyorum
Bu
Şarkı dinliyorum umut dolu
için o şikayetten çıkıyor you mutlu
oluyor huzurlu olalım
hepinizin yolunu umutla kesiştiği günler
olsun diyorum teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]